hi hello how are you good to see you i
can't hear myself but i'm assuming that
i'm here
welcome back to five nights at freddy's
2.
you don't see anything or don't hear
anything because i haven't loaded it yet
and because if you're watching this in
the future
you're watching an archive which is
pretty much the same as any other video
that i posted online this is an archive
of what happened and what happened a
long time ago is that i played five
nights at freddy's 2
which i
have quoted have been quoted as saying
and by quoted i mean there's a video of
me saying it that it was probably one of
my favorite five nights at freddy's
games ever made
but that was years ago that was many
many many years ago it's been a long
long long long long time since i played
this game
so i'm curious to see how it's changed
hello hi hello everybody
welcome
back
to five nights at freddy's two
ah
oh yeah
[Music]
look at that
just this like haunting cry
in the darkness
this like echoing
weird bird-like
chirp
like i said when i revisited five nights
at freddy's one
probably very loud by the way sorry
about that
that
five nights at freddy's one set the tone
when you played it like it really
established the feel of what it was and
i remember back in the day everyone
thought that this was going to be a
sequel with all the new and improved
animatronics but then it was a prequel
um but still that opening sequence in
the same way as five nights at freddy's
one just put you in this mood of
uncomfortableness because you had the
familiarity of looking out at the
pizzeria from five nights at freddy's
one and then you had this kind of like
new point of view to be looking at it
from it's super weird to be looking at
it from freddy's eyes you know what i
mean
i know i know the game was loud it was
it was right there whatever
i i'm doing it live i know what i'm
doing i don't know what i'm doing but
i'm gonna pretend like i know what i'm
doing so long long long long long time
ago i got into this without knowing
anything about it and now i'm gonna see
if it still holds up after all that time
what is
time's effect on me playing this versus
then and i remember when i played five
nights at freddy's one if you haven't
seen that video it's on my channel
called five nights at freddy's revisited
um i said that it still held up it
really did and i remember when i was
playing this by removing the doors it
just put a different sense of terror
into the game
so i'm gonna get into this and i'm gonna
see what's going on
and i'm probably gonna die
grand free opening
wow
a hundred dollars a week
good stuff
anyway yes i
no this won't be edited this is just me
live reactions to what it once were
and how
that is the way that it be
and yes
the bite of 87.
oh my god yeah i use this office for
like every thumbnail of five minutes
just because it's so good with these
hello and welcome to your new summer job
at the new and improved freddy fazbear's
pizza
uh i'm here to talk you through some of
the things you can expect to see during
your first week here to help you get
started down this new and exciting
career path
uh now i want you to forget anything you
may have heard about the old locations
you know
some people still have a somewhat
negative impression of the company
uh
that old restaurant was kind of left to
rot for quite a while but i want to
reassure you
fastberry entertainment is committed to
family fun and above all
they've spent a small fortune on these
new animatronics
facial recognition
advanced mobility they even let them
walk around during the day
isn't that neat
but most importantly
they're all tied into some kind of
criminal database so they can detect a
predator a mile away hey we should be
paying them to guard you
now that being said no new system is
without its
kinks
you're only the second guard to work at
that location uh the first guy finished
his week but complained about
conditions
uh we switched him over to the day shift
so hey lucky right
mainly his first concern that certain
characters seem to move around at night
and even attempted to get into his
office
now from what we know that should be
impossible that restaurant should be the
safest place on earth so while our
engineers don't really have an
explanation for this the working theory
is that
the robots were never given a proper
night mode so when it gets quiet they
think they're in the wrong room so then
they go try to find where the people are
in this case that's your office
so our temporary solution is this
there's a music box over by the fire
counter and it's rigged to be wound up
remotely so just every once in a while
switch over to the prize counter video
feed and wind it up for a few seconds
it doesn't seem to affect all of the
animatronics but it does affect
one of them
uh
and as for the rest of them we have an
even easier solution
you see there may be a minor glitch in
the system something about the robot
thing uses
so hey we've given you an empty pretty
fast bear head problem solved you can
put it on any time and leave it on for
as long as you want eventually anything
that wandered in will wander back out
uh something else worth mentioning is
kind of the quirky modern design of the
building
you may have noticed there are no doors
for you to close
but hey you have life and even though
your flashlight can run out of power the
building cannot so don't worry about the
place going dark
well i think that's it uh you should be
golden uh check the lights put on the
pretty head if you need to
keep the music box wound up piece of
cake have a good night and i'll talk to
you tomorrow
piece of cake piece of cake i mean it
really does set the tone i remember
going into this and just being like
there's no doors and then being
overwhelmed with the number of things
that i have to do one of my one of my
favorite things about it is just being
able to like look at the uh
look at the cameras with a flashlight
not like even a lot of the five nights
at freddy's fan games don't have that
because it just adds this other layer
and i i don't remember looking too deep
into all the things that were in the
rooms itself as far as like weirdness
that was happening
but i do like it it's super cool because
you get this thing where you see oh
there they are and then who the hell is
that and then you got the weirdness here
all the goodies you know what i mean
and oh they're on the move already ah
how you doing how you doing that was
kind of like this
i the whole idea of the beak being gone
super weird all of it just strange
i'm burning my uh my flashlight battery
by hi
how you doing good to see you
um but yeah it's so crazy to be back i i
i forget where the honkable nose is
yeah there it is
like uh
after so long being away from it and and
really seeing it
and just with the like the level of
polish and oops
i almost forgot about that that would
have been a problem
so it's uh it's just it's just kind of
crazy to see it all over again
oh god what is that
what is that
oh okay that's that's probably
right man the the sounds
still get me to this day like
oh god something's about to go into the
vent
weird oh
so strange to be back after all this
time
and i'm still really really good at the
game i think i think
um
god well there we go what do i do to
stop you again do i put on the mask i
feel like i put on the mask
all right hi
oh
you're supposed to be there i don't
remember
[Music]
oh
i'm a dead man
i've forgotten how to play completely
i'm a dead man aren't i i'm a dead man
i'm a dead man i'm a dead man i'm a dead
man i'm a dead man i'm a dead man
oh man it really is still terrifying
it's still terrifying to this day
still terrifying
still
hurry play oh
is that close enough to be a problem i
think they actually have to go in the
room before they're actually a problem
i don't really remember
hello peekaboo
still got it
man this this 20 mode was
the biggest [ __ ] i remember
just because the sheer number i mean
obviously the
the custom knight 20 mode is the biggest
[ __ ]
but
i never had time to get good at that
maybe maybe someday i actually will like
revisit that
uh if i'm doing these revisits
but
cause essie
cause not doing that 20 mode bothers me
a little more than i thought it would
you know what i mean
it bothers me a little more
than i thought it might
so i'm kind of like if i go back to
ultimate custom night which i might i
might do that again
i would try to be i know that there are
good strategies nowadays but just
you know what it is i want to listen to
these calls i actually like it
uh hello hello
uh see how i told you your first night
wouldn't be a problem you're a natural
uh by now i'm sure you've noticed the
older models sitting in the back room
those are from the previous locations
and we just use them for parts now the
idea at first was to repair them
they even started retrofitting them with
some of the newer technology but they
were just so ugly you know
the smell
so the company decided to just go in a
whole new direction and make them super
kid-friendly
those older ones shouldn't be able to
walk around but if they do the whole
freddy head trick should work on them
too so whatever
what uh
i love those old characters uh did you
ever see foxy the pirate
oh wait [ __ ]
oh yeah foxy uh hey listen uh that one
was always a bit twitchy uh
i'm not sure if the freddy head trick
will work on foxy uh if for some reason
he activates during the night and you
see him standing at the front
something's undesirable might be
it might hold him in fight for a few
seconds
that glitch might have carried over to
the newer models too
one more thing don't forget the music
box
i'll be honest i never liked that puppet
thing it's always
thinking
and i can go anywhere
i don't think the cream ass will fool it
so just don't forget the music box ah
don't forget anyway i'm sure it won't be
a
night and i'll talk problem you tomorrow
thanks
thank you
love you bye
oh okay who's who's where you're there
okay
all right then
oh god it's just so
it's it's it's cool i i still think that
it's cool there's a reason why
this type of game holds up
is because number one like the the
graphics itself
you know you can say what you want about
them if they're your type or not
or
you can think of it this way as like as
terms of like 3d modeling uh it still
looks nice but the core experience of
all these things is like the gameplay
right that that has to be first and
foremost above all else and it's just so
snappy like just changing things is so
snappy like it's so quick
it's just
it's still it's still probably my
favorite
five nights at freddy's game
just ma i mean it's a pain in the ass of
course but still
wow
i'm getting my old speed back
up
man these knights are longer than i
remember them
does it does the
i can't remember if this was a thing he
said something about like it might work
on any
of the animatronics
uh
would that work on mangle does does
flashing light and mangle actually make
him kind of stay still i don't remember
hi that's a problem
well they're both there so that's that's
good good to know
yep
well that's problem
okay
man even even balloon boy being out just
like
bizarre things to actually have him here
and knowing that this was like the
origin of where like i mean there was
lore in five nights at freddy's one
don't get me wrong but like the sheer
amount
of uh
possibilities that this game opened up
in terms of
you know what i mean
it's just nuts to think about what are
you doing man
where did you come from were you in the
vent i thought i looked in the vent
there was balloon boy in the vent where
were you
oh wait that's right
wait no i thought
doesn't chica come out of the left one
why am i am i dumb
am i some kind of a dumb am i big dumb i
might be big dumb am i big dumb guys
doesn't chica come out of the left one
or did she come out of the right one
i don't even remember anyway first jump
scare who's that the bite of 87
was that the bite of 87 let me try a
little
was that the bite of 87
anyway uh since i died what i'm gonna do
since you're all here
did you know in space with markiplier is
coming out did you know i did a live
stream where i watched the trailer a
hundred times did you know that if you
haven't seen the trailer the link is in
the description and you should go check
it out it's gonna be a great show it
comes out on april 4th and guess what
it's free so check the link in the
description below if you haven't seen it
already and if you've only seen it once
you have 90 more times 99 more times to
watch it
so get to watch it
anyway i gotta beat this i ain't gonna
die like that
thank you mods thank you thank you mods
i appreciate
all right so what did i do wrong i don't
know chica came at me
whatever that's what it is
i was doing good on uh keeping
unless i mean it's only night too so
what can i really say about how i'm
keeping people in place
but you know
it is god just being able to mash that
button
was that the bite of 87 if you want to
see the bite of 87 you better check out
the link in the description below the
truth of all five nights at freddy's
lore is in the link in the description
below and if you don't click it you'll
never know because the video is going to
get deleted very soon you gotta check it
out for yourself and you don't know that
i'm lying you have no idea
it could be the truth
maybe i'm joking you or maybe it really
is
you'll never know until you click it
god
god or did i
maybe you think you're about to be god
but you're not going to be god because
all the secret to the bite of 87 is in
the link in the description below
why not check it out and find out what
do you have to lose
what do i have to lose my life probably
man these nights are long
my microphone isn't low your volume's
too low
actually probably just have the gaming
music a little too loud there we go
i don't know i always like mixing it a
little
louder but i can't really tell in my
headphones where my
voice is
check one two i never do any kind of a
setup
i'm not exactly professional
i'm not one of those
incredible streamers
i don't mean that sarcastically i know
streaming is a tough gig
i like the whole video making process
and then i go home well i go home and
then i work on a show called in space
with markiplier that you need to see
which is coming out
april 4th hi
how you doing
no one's really moving
i thought they would have been i mean i
guess there was a long phone call
so they probably only really start
giddying up
hey cut it out
and only really start going
when you
get done with the call which probably
would have been right about now
i don't know
let me do an experiment
hey got that [ __ ]
who the hell do you think you are stop
the speed
that's what it always is about right
these games just about going as fast as
humanly possible
clickety click click clackety click
click i mean that's what it was when i
played like the the 20 modes is just
like
just as focused try not to blink for
about eight minutes straight hi what do
i do about you i don't even remember
what do i do i i forget what i do about
balloon boy is there anything dad do
about balloon boy i don't think so
hey you just what do you do
what do you do i forget what you do what
do you do
oh is he there forever now
wait
oh
damn you balloon boy
damn you [ __ ]
you goddamn [ __ ]
ah
this oh
right
and this is the first introduction of
this
this idea
of
i don't remember that
this idea of these like old old old old
shoe games like atari level games
just like it's
god it's super cool there's just so much
baked into this one and i get like the
trap that's easy to fall into as far as
like making further games and there have
been like some hits and some misses here
and there i personally didn't really
like three that much i thought three was
kind of like yeah to me maybe it's
because i never really had a full grasp
on the mechanics of it it just felt like
i lucked my way through it half of the
time um but four
the nightmare one was actually kind of
interesting it was kind of like a return
to roots of
five nights at freddy's but then sister
location came out and sister location
was awesome i really enjoyed that as
just like a pure game with like the
story being involved as well and like
having all that and exotic butters you
get all those good things like it's just
like it all mixes up pretty nicely and
then you get like this concoction of
five nights at freddy's goodness i did i
i do think sister location i don't know
but this one is quite good
now i can't remember exactly what i do
to balloon boy
to get him to go away
i can't remember i i think when he's
there just put the mask on otherwise
he's going to screw you because i
couldn't do anything and that's kind of
like the game over that's in five nights
at freddy's one so
what does it really matter
oh
my
muscle memory needs to recalibrate
what happens
take this
take this take this take this
i think it's masked prior to him uh
getting out of the the vent i think
that's what it is right
unless i because i think that if he's
there
probably nothing you could do about it
right
probably anyway
anyway remember all the secrets to the
lore of five nights at freddy's i've
made a video about it uh the link is in
the description i've unlocked all the
secrets that box with two locks on it i
have unlocked it it is through the link
in the description below if you click on
that you will find all the hidden lore
to five nights at freddy's and you can
rest assured
that i'm telling the truth absolutely
why would i lie
i am the most honest person on youtube i
will make that statement and i will say
it loud and i will say it proud
and no one can prove me otherwise link
in the description there's a video down
there
uh click on that and you will learn
everything that there is to know about
five nights at freddy's and i am not
fooling why would i fool
i look at this smile
that's not a lion smile that's truthful
smile we all know we all know yeah the
the the actual footage of the bite of 87
is actually down in the link in the
description below if you click on that
you will you will observe uh the truth
of the bite of 87 and 83 you will find a
bite of 83 as well down there um and
then you will find um
golden freddy he's he's there too and uh
all in one video i kind of like did a
nice nice succinct wrapping up of the
entirety of five nights at freddy's in
that one video
down in the description that link down
there definitely click it it's
100 true hey hey hey get out of there
all right you got her
you got her
you get out of there yeah
yeah fine
whatever
hannity
i love
winding a music box okay where are you
going you're going there i think uh the
reason it does that is just when you uh
can't it's just like the cameras right
when they're moving that's probably bad
hmm
well
probably ain't good but oh he's gone
yep
that's probably not good
who's in the vents oh hey what's up
balloon [ __ ]
oh well that can't be good
hey buddy
[Music]
ah that is how you do it okay i've
solved it i've solved the problem just
like i've solved the lore of this game
available through the link in the
description below for a limited time
only
go check it out if you want to uh
know everything
also i gotta remember there are audio
cues for all of this
you know what i mean there's audio cues
for the vent movement so if you can
count in your head
the vent movement
you start to get a better understanding
just like that
start to get a better understanding of
what's going on there which is why i got
to listen to this nice and loud
who's in the who's there
who's there hey hey hey
hi
hi
hey guy
hey stupid fox
got her
get out of here oh you're okay
god i remember ah man that's what i
loved about custom night is it was very
like uh self-aware so you had you know
toy freddy playing five nights at
freddy's or whatever was it like some
kind of a mop game something like that
just super fun
just like cool ideas
uh throughout it but i love getting to
the point where you're you're so
self-aware that you just make fun of the
memes the community have made about the
game and that's kind of like
that's kind of like what's really cool
about all this i think i put on the mask
i think i put on the mask for that i'm
i'm pretty sure
you still there i'm
i'm i'm pretty sure
he's not there oh you get out here get
out of here
get out of here
get out of here
guy it also is weird because
there is still this weird muscle memory
baked into my hands for playing this
game
and it's it's like riding a bicycle
right except uh the bicycle is about to
bite your frontal lobe off if you crash
so that's why you wear a helmet or
otherwise a freddy mask because
otherwise your frontal lobe is going to
go bye-bye
and we don't want that
oh hello
how did you get there
hey what are you doing hey what the hell
who
i just
i forgot that they could switch spots
like that
it was like you know balloon boy comes
up behind chica
and chica doesn't want balloon boy
behind her so and i understand that hey
how you doing the [ __ ] off
and then just politely backing out of
the vents so that
when i heard that i heard that
politely backing out of the vents so
that
the spot can be taken all right so we
got plenty of we got double vents at the
moment
i'm about to run out of battery come on
do something
do something
do something if you're so brave
do something you want to fight me i
didn't think so you didn't think i'd be
back after what eight years i almost did
the camera
okay and the wind up mangle hasn't been
a problem this time
no this is not the bite of 87 because
the bite of 87 will not occur
man i'm good man i'm still good beat
knight two just like that whoa
this i love this
this is probably my favorite part of
this game the mini games are cool and
all literally this sequence i have yet
to see
any kind of game
any movie really truly replicate the
unease and the terror that this sequence
fulfills
because it's not just about the setup
and the setting that you're in it's
about the understanding of what's
happening right
you're you had the previous sequence at
the beginning of the game and you know
this sequence where you were looking and
now chica is looking at you and bonnie
is looking at you and it's separated
separated by such a gap of time that you
almost have forgotten about the sequence
and then you get this bizarreness
occurring
it's super cool it's so cool
probably not i was just curious
like i said he was always my favorite
they tried to remake foxy you know they
thought the first one was too scary so
they redesigned them to be more kit
friendly and put them in kids cove
to keep the toddlers entertained you
know
but kids these days just can't keep
their hands to
themselves the staff literally had to
put foxy back together into every ship
eventually they just stopped trying and
left him in some kind of
take apart put back together attraction
now he's just a mess of parts i think
the employees refer to them as just the
mangle
uh oh hey before i go i wanted to ease
your mind about any rumors you might
have heard lately uh do you know how
these local stories come and go and sell
them anything i can personally assure
you that whatever is going on out there
however tragic it may be has nothing to
do with our establishment this is all
rumor and speculation people trying to
make a buck you know
our guard during the day has reported
[Applause]
okay bye love you bye okay cool so yeah
this is where the story starts to get
dark and i kind of love this idea of
storytelling where you get
uh you get a greater understanding of
where you are
after the fact and what's going on after
the fact it's kind of the whole concept
of like
subverting expectations or whatever like
that
that's nerve wracking i don't like that
i don't like that nun
i don't know why that's
it no that's that's i don't think that's
bro that's a problem oh my god that is
the most terrifying thing i've seen in a
while
just like this concept of things being
completely broken i love it you know i
honestly truly do love it i think that's
a problem i think he's very close
am i gonna die i'm gonna die oh boy
i seem fine
i think it's the same kind of recipe for
them yeah they gotta go through the
vents first
there's no other way around for them to
go
they have to do the vents but it's just
it's so cool right it's so cool you know
what else is so cool space in space with
markiplier launches april 4th right here
on my channel completely free for you
the people if you haven't seen the
trailer yet go to my channel and look
for the in space with markiplier trailer
available also for free on my channel
i've conveniently put it in the link in
the description below just for you
along with the lore the lore is also
there who the hell
do you think you are
stop
being
you
is anybody peeking their head out nah i
didn't think so
dude
easy peasy guy why did i have a problem
with this before this seems
laughable
hey stop it
stop it
oh i
forgot that's what they do
that's what they do is that what the toy
uh ones do too do they do do you have to
wait until they actually pop out in the
hallway i thought they attacked right
from the
the vent which is
so it's weirdly quiet all of a sudden
god that's bizarre i've always thought
like when you're when you're playing
games or watching a movie the absence of
sound can be scarier than anything
because it's all about like what you
think you're ready for right it's what
you what you're expecting
and then when some something doesn't go
according to plan that's when things
could get really
really freaky like
a lot of sound can be scary you know in
the amnesia the dark descent games you
know you have the chase sequence music
that's iconic and it's just like
thumping and you feel like something is
about to bite your neck off
and and then you get this like
uh lulling moments of like softer sounds
and softer like it's still ghostly but
it's it's softer it's not loud um but
that between that and like a complete
absence of sound
that
is just
uh
but as 4am i'm actually doing quite well
i'm on 83 already guys i think i'm
actually going to go through all the
five nights i don't know if i'm gonna go
to like the bonus nights and you know
yada yada the other nights and whatnot
but i'm gonna see this through at least
hey all right
hi hi what are you doing
god that looming look
it's so s freaking scary
what's going on what's happening
that cool that is just terrifying
what's happening here okay you're both
in there both of the chicas are there
oh hey
i forgot that that's forgiving because
that just
that just uh oh i didn't check the vents
oh my god
that just that's very forgiving because
he's he's kind enough to pull the camera
down for my face and then eat me he's
got to check to make sure
make sure i'm not in the criminal
database
who
who's
oh you switched spots
interesting well seniority i guess
i think they're the same way too they
they don't they don't appear
in the
you know they don't appear
in the alcove they just to pop up the
old ones are actually easier to deal
with
to be perfectly honest
i see you down there
hello
okay
it's about being as sparing as possible
with that flashlight because i know down
the road i mean not really i guess i
i've i've been slapping around the old
deal
ah i guess i did it hey call me
i'm the best
i am great you know what else
my god is this thing
i just love this
i'm i'm like in love i've been in love
with like the sound and the sequence
since i've used this sound so many times
when i do like stupid secret crap i put
in the end
oh
[Music]
oh
no
[Music]
it's me there was an it's me behind my
face you couldn't see it but whatever
but it's so good it's so goddamn good
it's just so good and you know what else
is good the trailer to my upcoming
youtube original show that will be
available completely for free for you on
april 4th in space with markiplier link
in the description along with the same
link that goes up
[Music]
though that it's really just a
precaution
that's where entertainment denies
anywhere i'm doing
these things happen sometimes
it'll all get sorted out in a few days
just keep an eye on things and i'll keep
you posted
just as a side note though
trying to avoid eye contact with any of
the animatronic side of the cam
someone may have tampered with their
facial recognition
we're not sure but the characters have
been acting very unusual almost
aggressive towards the fact
they interact with the kids just fine so
when they encounter themselves they just
stare
anyways
good night
good night
god i forgot how
quick the winding
goes down now
i forgot like it's like you have to like
slam that freaking computer up every
single time
i wish you could turn your head faster i
think i remember saying that back in the
day
like just if you could turn your head
faster i would be a very happy man
i'd be so happy
hello foxy boy what's she doing over
there
see it seems like mangle's kind of stuck
there because i keep having to flip it
open and
you know slap him with a few lights here
and there
maybe that is is that the trick to
handling him i have no idea it's been so
long
because i would figure that they are and
he's moved whatever where did he go you
get out of there oh my god
what the [ __ ] was that what
what the [ __ ] was that
what
ah
have i ever seen that
have i ever seen that
what the i thought that was a photoshop
what the hell was that
have i seen that did i see that in my
i'm actually i'm flabbergasted my dudes
i am
my gasps are all flabbered
i i don't know what the hell just
happened my i'm gonna run out of
flashlight because i'm slapping it too
much
shadow bonnie
okay
because i i've seen that character in
future games
i was
like what the hell
have i seen that in this game
specifically i've definitely seen
that before
but i remember it from ultimate custom
night
did i see it
in this game i remember seeing golden
freddy i've seen golden freddy here
before
but not
what the hell
oh god
i have not i did god damn that's crazy
right actually i thought it was time to
i was uh my gasps are flabbered
what the frick have i seen that
well i must not have been paying
attention that's fine
it's fine guys it's fine
what is that
it's like a point zero zero one percent
chance
what
point zero zero one percent chance
and i got it
what did i do
streamer luck yeah
good god okay um
well
i am shaking and crying rn
most definitely
good
god
all right
i'll go again
i'll go again but on one condition
on one condition and one condition only
and that's that you go to the link in
the description below and you watch the
in space with markiplier trailer you
watch that and you come back here you go
there you leave a comment you say i
watch this
i watch this
leave a like come back i'll play more
and i'll see if i can shadow bonnie
again is there anything to do about that
because yeah i remember in five nights
at freddy's 3 there were all those like
other shadow versions of the
animatronics but but listen
listen
you
you
better go down there in the link in the
description below you better click that
you better go comment i watch this
and then come back or some variation of
that leave a like come back
and i'll play more yeah
if you haven't noticed i'm very excited
about in space with markiplier coming
out and i want you all to see it
because it's really good we did uh we
did a little fringe premiere yesterday
um over at ethan's place we did a little
friend premiere and uh
it's just it was so nice to see
like number one i've seen the show
because i've been obviously in the
editing process and non-stop but it's
it's just like it's crazy to see it
played through and it was so fun to see
like the choices that they made
uh to get where they did uh no spoilers
at all like if you couldn't tell like
heist it's interactive and he was just
like oh it's so fun i can't wait to see
you guys play it
on my channel for april 4th but the link
in the description below is the trailer
to that
yeah quid pro quo whatever that means
that's happening all right
so if you have done that and i'm watch
i'm watching actually you know what i
can know i actually can know if you're
going i can know and i will know because
i'm gonna look right now see if if this
deal that we're striking right here is
actually going through
mm-hmm
[Music]
okay all right some some some definitely
some have
of the
90 000 people here 90 000 people uh
five thousand of you went and you know
what
it's not enough
that's not enough
i know you didn't go because i can see
that you didn't go because i've got
real-time analytics youtube has
empowered me with real-time analytics so
i can see exactly when people do or do
not do the thing that i say and ask very
nicely and basically hold hostage
what i say and do i see and you know do
some of you did and i proud of you but
so many almost all did not because i see
and i see that you didn't you were
trying to cheat me you crashed stay here
instead of supporting this amazing show
that so many people have worked so hard
on
i see
i see the truth of your actions i see it
okay good all right let's go let's go
let's keep going
sorry i just got so
emotional i appreciate it i was just
shaking and crying for a little bit
there just just a little shaking and
crying rn
nothing too dramatic
also like and subscribe
ring that bell
whatever the professional youtubers say
these days
i don't know something about something
about smashing a like button or
something do that
hit that like bring uh smash that bell
the comment that's something oh add to
your favorites is that still a thing i
don't think so put me on your watch
later playlist
oh god
in that short amount of time between me
playing then and now i have completely
forgotten how to play the game
not lying guys i've completely forgotten
how to play the muscle memory is gone
and i'm relying on pure instinct now
this is all i have and this is all
that'll carry me through
i hope it's enough
anyway i appreciate you guys thank you
so much for being here and allowing us
to do what we do and me to do what i do
i uh i'm just like this is that's that's
really the only thing that's reason i
keep hammering it's the reason i keep
hammering on things like distractible in
the new podcast with tyler uh if you
haven't heard of that one it's called go
my favorite sports team um i don't know
anything about sports but tyler has a
master's degree it's just like it's it's
really actually very fun
uh to hear him gush about things because
i haven't been able to do something with
tyler in a long time and you know i'm
really happy to have this project with
him and something that he can really
like be
incredible at and it's like he has an
encyclopediatic
knowledge of sports you know what i mean
oh wait a minute
wait oh no
oh god no
oh
oh no oh
i was talking
oh god
what do i do about that i i don't know
what to do about that i've completely
forgotten what to do i think it's like
eventually i die i think isn't that what
it is eventually i die oh god
oh ripperoni
oh
shadow bonnie take me
there it is
i completely forgot about that
i was boned it's true i was very boned
i watched this
it's okay guys it's okay i'm going right
back into it i am going to beat this i
am going to beat this i am i will beat
this i am in shaman will
beat this
that might have been the bite of 87
i'm not 100 sure about it but i have a
funny feeling that might have been the
bite of 87.
let me know if it gets too loud i'd like
to keep the volume a little bit up
anyway
i wonder if it's like
because he wasn't a problem before i
know it's probably just like randomized
versus these guys but i really do wonder
if i like charge him up with spamming
the flashlight on him if he feel like
that's like an internal nah oh
god what am i doing
actually press the windows key ah i did
it again i'm not on gaming mode
it should be fine i i don't think you
actually have to hit you know slap foxy
in the face too many times before he
goes away
maybe it's like an odd even thing
the odd number of flashes
on the mangle
doesn't come after you even number
does
hey
who the hell
you [ __ ]
god i wish i turned faster
oh actually i just realized it would be
a lot more efficient if i checked that
and then that and then just remembered
where i was next time check that and
that that that's much faster
because then i can check in one sweep
instead of two sweeps right is that what
i used to do i feel like that's
that's one of those pro strats that you
just like yeah man
you need an expert gamer like me to be
able to discern them
that's definitely what i did before
isn't it
who's in there
okay so now comes the real test
not dying
so far so good
still there huh
come on
i'm
so god damn good look at me on night
four
who's oh i almost did the thing again i
almost did the thing
gone
that was quick
okay easy enough
because that was the thing about plant
did i see some
blood stain you know it's fine that was
the thing about like um
uh
ultimate custom night is is as far as
speed goes like
i really did feel like
uh
20 20 mode
you know 20 times 50 mode might have
actually been beatable
uh
with no bugs right
i really kind of do because
whoa i did it too soon no
why am i in such a hurry no
oh my god i can't believe this i came
ashamed i'm ashamed i'm ashamed i don't
know why i do that too early i just do
that too early
oh
god
oh yeah i know that there's a bite of 83
and a bite of 87
whatever i it's the bite of 87 and
anything anyone says otherwise is just
being silly
uh
if if you if it's the bite of 87 and 83
i is the king of five nights at freddy's
hereby declare that
83 and 87 are now the same year and for
convenience they will be called 87. i
have decreed it
i haven't even declared it i decreed it
and so it has been decreed
we have destroyed the year of 83 through
some time
machine [ __ ]
83 no longer exists it's expunged from
the universe and only 87 resides
the year of 1987 is now twice as long as
it was before
to compensate for the uh
the gap in the time space continuum i
have decreed it
i have decreed it it has been decreed
who is slapping around
all right this time i'm not going to die
to some stupid shenanigans
not today not ever i'm not even doing my
pro strat i was doing before
oh look at the speed saving look at the
speed saving who's there
come on
there you go
all right
you gonna go
thank you
some kind of a danger going on
that stupid noise is slamming around in
my ears
don't know why mangle is not being a
bother today
tonight
in this place the bite of 89
don't you get me started on 89
i can't expunge 89 that's the year of my
birth so i would be expunged from the
universe should i
be at that time and no i will not
expunge 87 because that's the year of my
brother's birth and i will not expunge
that
i use my power wisely
wisely
very wisely
and as a mercy to you all those of you
who may or may not
have been born in 83 or know someone
that has been born
i what
i will allow them to now
retroactively be born in 87
but they may be they may get bit it's
just that's a danger it's a 50 50 shot
honestly there probably was a bite in
every single year of this game
who is in there
ah interesting
well i didn't wind up at all
hi
right
okay i'm not gonna do it early
okay definitely gone
wait was there something
ah there was someone there there was
many someone's there
who
this
balloon [ __ ] again
okay
oh
not early not early
i know i can do it as soon as the sound
goes it's like i'm not
oh no
oh it's not when the sound goes
i thought it was when the sound stopped
no
i got this i got this guys i thought it
was when the sound stopped that's what i
did it wasn't that what i based it on
before
i thought that's what i based it on
before
i
decree
that there needs to be a patch to this
game such that
when the sound stops
it's time to lower the mask and i will
not accept anything otherwise but the
sound cue being perfectly in sync with
that i am decreeing it
i wonder if slamming the flashlight in
any of these other spots actually does
anything
i feel like it must right why else would
they put because that was the thing
about this game is is i always felt like
the problem is the more the more you go
into the game the more i want to see
what's changing around here because
there often are like really interesting
things going on there's secrets that are
going there but when you get into like
the quote-unquote meta of the game and
trying to actually beat it
you you end up just
seeing
nothing basically you end up seeing this
room and that's it
you know
and that's it and it's kind of a shame
because
like there's so much room to see and i
know i'm gonna try to break that mold
because
it's my own fault because i do it too i
just get caught up in it and i'm like oh
i gotta make sure the music box wound oh
i definitely don't have time to look at
anything else and yet i do you know you
do you do have time and you should look
around because that's part of the fun is
like exploring what's happening later in
the game and
how the world is changing around you
that's what makes it fun
like knowing when you have time to do
things maybe that's why things come
after me so hard
later on
it's just because i don't do enough
looking around and if i did more looking
around
i might actually see
that my
flashing of screens
has an effect and maybe there's some
preventative stuff to be done
i don't know
it's all theory but uh
just a theory
a game theory
thanks for watching
uh matpat ow or whatever i don't know
however he says his things
i gotta do a response video to his uh as
a pokemon yeah
okay
uh don't worry i'll do a very
comprehensive and thorough response to
it uh in video essay format mla
sources cited
i'm gonna do all the works like you know
me whenever i go into something i go
hard into that thing what the frick what
oh that's mangle i i see i've never seen
him there before because i've never
looked
and that's kind of the crazy thing is
like i so rarely see him in these spots
because i'm never moving anywhere
hi
oh that's weird yeah see i never really
think of them being there i don't see
these guys in the hallway
i don't do any of the cool stuff
he's back over there now that's kind of
cool
come here give me yeah hey how you doing
and i'm assuming that uh bonnie will let
me know oh god i've i've been using my
flashlight way too much
i got to be super sparing now
okay
oh god
very spooky
this gotta be sparing i gotta make this
last a long time
oh do you have to have the the the fog
clear completely also no
that's annoying i'm annoyed i decreed it
and
scott hasn't changed it yet
you have to wait until the the gray
overlay goes completely gone
boom
boom
[Music]
boom
[Music]
all right fine i'm gonna get this this
time don't you guys worry you're worried
i can feel that you're worried
don't be worried there's no reason to be
why would you be worried
hi
don't be worried guys it's all good
that is the thing though about this game
is
is this like
you can feel like you've got a handle on
things
but the thing about these games always
is like one mistake and you're dead kind
of like elkin ring in a way or any of
the dark souls game well i mean if you
if you're not playing it right and you
have actual health and maybe not one
mistake you're dead but
pretty much at any moment you mess up
once and you're gone
and that's you know it's not the most
common thing in my mind anyway in games
these days a lot of them like to hold
hands
and this game really didn't hold your
hand
because i mean the deeper you go the
harder it gets to the point where it's
nearly impossible for pretty much
anybody who actually has sanity to try
to beat the hardest version of it
um
but a lot of games and a lot of what i
was seeing about critique on let's say
elden ring again because i've been
playing that a lot
um it's just like
that
the user experience is bad or whatever
it's other game developers like saying
things and performance issues aside
because there were some performance
issues on pc that's legitimate criticism
but when it comes down to like
uh
the game itself not having a quest log
not having anything uh that guides you
where you go except for a little bit of
glitter every now and then pointing you
in a direction um and you know that's
enough
because
the whole point of having like an open
world game is to explore and when i play
elder ring the great thing about it is
that
i literally
can go in any direction
and i'll find something new i'll find
new things all the time and and that's
kind of like what this game what i love
about it is is you can look
in different place it doesn't tell you
you need to look at the other cameras
and eventually you could not look at
them but the thing is
this whole world is here around you and
whether you like it or not what should
not be alive
is somehow alive around you and you you
get to look at that i almost brought up
the camera
and i'm gonna wait for this to
completely clear
what did i do
wait does he need something different
oh
he needs something different doesn't he
was it too slow it's probably just too
slow i shouldn't be talking
is it too slow i keep like wanting to go
to the uh to the uh the console instead
oh it's too slow
right okay
i am speed
that's right that was a strategy before
too wasn't it
was isn't there a button to like
directly put on the mask
isn't there a button for that
wasn't there a button is there a button
to put on the mask
oh god
you're too slow all right don't worry
guys
don't worry guys i got it okay
got it nailed it
i'll show you too slow
get ready for speed
that's right that's what i said that's
what i call speed who's in there
not today not today
that's what i thought that's what i
thought you couldn't even see my moves
it's almost like i was wearing them
gone
so i can do it when the sound is there
it's just that i have to
be ready
to slam it immediately so i can go when
the sound is gone is like in those times
i was dead
that's what i remember okay
i i appreciate that most of you guys
first instinct was not that i was too
slow but i am hereby insulted
that you didn't hold me accountable for
mistakes that i could have prevented
that's i no matter what i will figure
out a way to blame you and i appreciate
that
just trying to get the
muscle memory
what's going on around here
am i in danger
go away
he's really hanging out there
don't worry i got this guys
i can't get in the habit of doing that
every time i put that down because it
doesn't need to happen
movements and all that
whoa
interesting
that was a really fast mangle
guys you wouldn't believe it
i'm try harding
mangle's back
i'm ready
i'm so ready i'm done dying
oh [ __ ]
i wonder if you're fast enough on those
if they if they leave faster based on
how quick you were you know what i mean
nah i think it's random
but so far so good oh god that might not
have been fast enough that might not
have been fast enough
god damn it
i wasn't ready for it all that time
preparing and i wasn't ready for it oh
all that time stuck
am i
you're too slow oh
all right guys
get ready for speed all right
i know what it is i know what the
problem is guys
guys i know what the problem
not enough of you have clicked the link
in the description below
my speed is entirely based on how much
you guys support me
how much you guys want me to succeed in
life
is the basis the fundamental basis of my
speed
without that
without your love
and support
i'm nothing
i'm dust in the wind
not enough of you have clicked the link
in the description below
and checked out my compilation video of
all the fundamental basis of lore in
this game forever and ever answers to
all the questions not enough of you have
done that i feel myself withering away
i guess you guys don't
support me anymore
i get it
i get it
i understand
i couldn't possibly be living up to the
expectations of the past
who am i
but a shadow of my former self
i see that now
i bet you guys haven't even rung that
bell
i bet you guys haven't even smashed the
like button
i feel it
in my bones
my aching
aging bones
i am
not
a glimmer in the eye of fate
a day's long pass
to you
and i see that clearly now
but mayhaps may haps if you click the
link in the description below i might
just be able to get enough life force
inside me
to be able to beat this with the speed
it needs
but maybe
mayhaps only if you click that link in
the description below only if you do
that
only if you prepare yourselves for what
is coming on april 4th of 2022
only may have to do that that i could
have that for me from you
your love and support
i think my brain goes into a sub routine
where it just fills
any space with inane [ __ ] so that i
can actually contemplate what is
happening in front of my face
and so it frees up a lot of brain power
even right now i actually don't
understand what i'm saying or what's
coming out of my mouth but i'm just
hoping that it's coherent enough that
you guys can get a
vague understanding of what i'm trying
to say but in all honesty i'm pretty
much asleep at this moment
who's there lore be damned
i got a box to wind
and i got a face mask to slam
i guess i can relax a bit
why be so try hard
really no reason
i don't even know why i'm looking at the
sides it's not like they're doing
anything to me anyway
okay so
now bonnie is here
and bonnie is really thinking about it
oh chica's thinking about it
that's what it is right
okay so i should yeah okay so i got that
right that's why i got in the habit
of slamming that down
because
when i uh there's a way to know
what they're doing before they do it
right
i get it because if they're in the vent
then theoretically the next event noise
must be them moving out of the vent and
into the room and therefore i would know
to slam the mask down
before i even get there i just need to
get the
the tablet up
so that i can see
what's going on
right
i am basically making them do what they
need to do
right
it was all of your your loving i was not
ready i was not ready i'm dead that was
way too slow
i'm alive i'm alive your loving support
sustained me
your love and support guys it was your
support it was how hard you slammed that
like button it was you
you did this you did this to me i feel
life force surging up inside of me
i feel the effervescent spirit of the
earth
coursing through my butthole
i cannot
i can't even sustain its
magnanimousness
i'll never
i'll never live down what i just said
what happened
what just happened
i have no idea again once again i went
into a fugue state
my brain vacated my skull for a few
moments
hi freddie welcome to the party
gotcha [ __ ]
so it is when the sound goes it is when
the sound goes but i have to be
ready for that eventuality because
freddy's there which means that he could
pop up
at any given moment and frankly it might
be this given moment nope he's gone
where did he go i can look around now
that's a party here
who's there
who's there
i didn't think so
whoa
who's there
[Music]
all right once you get the once you get
the general beats of it down
i do wish there was a dedicated mask
button i think i remember people asking
for that when the game came whoa
that was a miss click
this is where i lose the game because i
accidentally pressed the wrong button
it was you
it was all of you
your love
your support your feelings of grandeur
we got shadow bonnie here we got this
nonsense uh
i forgot
i forgot about that i forgot about that
i forgot about that i forgot about that
i forgot about that i forgot about that
i forgot about that
i forgot about that
i forgot about that i forgot about that
i forgot about that
i'm shaking and crying
huh
it's me
it's me i love that so much i love that
now watch this sight read 100 no death
fifth night boom
dunzo dunyan rings
oh
hey good job nice five um hey
keep a close eye on things tonight okay
uh from what i understand the building
is on lockdown
no one is allowed in or out
especially concerning any previous
employees
um when we get it all sorted out we may
move into the day show the position just
became
available
we don't have a replacement for your
ship yet but we're working on it
we're gonna try to contact the original
restaurant owner
i think the name of the place was
fredbear's family diner or something
like that
was closed for years though i doubt
we'll be able to check
we'll
anybody
down
through one more night uh hang in there
good night
okay thank you love you bye thanks
thanks thanks so much all right we gotta
survive or whatever nonsense
all right watch this watch this oh the
lore oh god the realization that it's
prequel oh god shadow bonnie oh god for
those of you who missed it
uh apparently i got a rare thing called
shadow bonnie earlier in this
uh
what was that
so uh if you want to see that when this
video gets posted i don't remember what
time stamp it was but i definitely
didn't get that before
that definitely was not a thing that i
got
oh
hello
okay same old same old pretty much same
it's just got to be quick on those mask
downies
because if you're not quick you die and
i remember that being the most
frustrating thing before i don't know i
think i blocked it out of my memory the
concept of like having to be quick about
the mask
and it's like such a tiny window
because i i definitely remember that
but at the same
time this is perfectly manageable
hey you just moved
you just moved
who's moving
stop moving okay so the next event noise
is gonna be nope
i didn't even see chica get in the vent
i didn't even see chica get in the vent
i didn't even see she could get in the
vent
anyway
i'm gonna keep going
i got this that never happened expunge
it from your memory
your collective consciousness is being
wiped
you're going to forget a lot of
additional memories and accessory
memories you don't need those it doesn't
matter
you're fine just the way you are
for people that want to become a bimbo
apparently and i don't even know really
what the definition of bimbo is but
people call me a himbo
and i feel warm fuzzy feelings inside of
me when people say that about me so it
must be nice
or not
yeah i know
uh you'll never be able to see it though
the damn shame
lost to the ages
all right what was i doing i'm trying to
write
who's there
oh
is that balloon boy
oh thank you thank you for the uh
oh god oh
made it just like that
that's how good i am
god i gotta stop gonna stop getting
distracted i don't know just like my add
is like i get bored
you get bored doing the same thing over
and over again i might as well go
i was not prepared
i just gotta start getting in the habit
of slamming it
i just gotta get started
because that's what's killing me is like
that that little bit of hesitation there
at the beginning
it's like ah
i keep forgetting that they can get me
but i don't see them in the vents that's
the craziest thing
oh they don't appear in the side vent
right
they don't poke their head out
i forgot
they don't do that
oh
i'm an idiot
i'm an idiot
that's what i was like looking for and
i'm like oh why am i not seeing this i'm
not seeing them because they don't do
that right they go straight from the
vent into the room they don't wait
oh
oh
okay
right
theoretically i don't even need to check
these lights
for
i need to check barely anything really
kind of like a waste of time to do it
right
because knowing where they are is
infinitely more important
or knowing where they're going to be is
infinitely more important and knowing
where they're coming from
right
that's kind of the thing where i'm kind
of like maybe there is something to
this whole looking in other places
because the information that i gained
from that could save me time down the
road of like okay this guy's here this
guy's there right i'm thinking as if i'm
gonna actually try hard
the game but i'm just it's it's kind of
like this strange memory thing where i'm
starting to remember
the little lessons that i taught myself
earlier
in the game when i played this many a
moon ago
and i'm kind of like adding on to it too
because
there's little things to be gained
like little realizations and i might not
be completely right but i'm definitely
right about like knowing where they're
going and what to expect can mean that
like okay now i need to be ready for the
mask to come down
because i know
i saw some eyes there that was pretty
cool
you're there
ah so there's
there's bonnie he could hop in
a vent at any moment
pretty much
and he's about to he moves quick
so now i now i know i need to be ready
to slam this this down
because
he's he's waiting in line
come on
oh my god balloon boy you [ __ ]
what go away balloon boy go away
you [ __ ] i hate balloon boy i hate
him
just
just go away
i kept hearing
vent sounds so i was like oh he's gone
no
no he's not gone
no
oh that balloon [ __ ]
that balloon [ __ ]
all right this time all right first try
guys
we're gonna get him this time
man been a while since i played this
game
oh man i don't think i'm gonna die
i i know what it was because i kept
raising my mask sooner and it's like you
have to wait because he's just such a
dick
so why not do it
i don't even know why i'm checking those
i don't need to
hello oh oh
undesirable
chica that's who it was i knew i saw
something
see the benefit of checking the cameras
and they are they're all there
everyone's there
whoa was not ready for that
even though i should have been ready for
that who's in the vents there i need to
wind up okay be ready to
wham
not today huh
wham
what happened
something happened
i i did something good i don't know what
i did
that's
being a basket
yeah
okay
now we get it now we get it now we get
it okay
oh you bastard
you beware word god damn you
it was empty
it was clear it was clear it was clear
there was nothing in the vents i didn't
see
anything about bonnie
i didn't see anything about that
oh all right first try guys first try
first try
got this
got this easy peasy
this is what you get this is what you
get this is what you get this is what
you deserve this is what you deserve
this is what you get
take this and some of these
from buckle up get ready with your likes
and subscribes you hold them you hold
those likes and subscribes you hold them
on
pull them off
until i
and as soon as that clock strikes 6am
you unleash your likes and subscribes
you unleash them
right
down wherever you unleash them to
okay no one's in the wings
no one
no one's in the wings
now someone is in the wings
i've been doing too much flashlight
i don't even need the flashlight on
those in there
oh no
it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's fine it's totally fine
okay okay cheek is there she can pop out
at any moment i just need to be aware of
that
and she could bring my mask down
that's how we do
all right
now i'm gonna assume that that clanking
now
everything has a sound cue i know this
is
something bad
i just saw
bonnie in the hallway chica in the right
wing
which means that's chica entering the
thing or mangle no it's chica
okay so what this means oh
my god i'm done
okay i'm probably gonna get this pulled
down on me
next up i think i got that i definitely
got that
cool
definitely got that okay freddy's there
wind up the box
and then get ready for a face full of
fred
what is it what do you feel like looking
at your own face [ __ ]
does it feel like looking at your own
take some of face
and one of these
i thought you could get me with it
cheap moves like that not today oh it's
the
little baby version of yourself
okay he's in there
that's okay
i am running uh low on
or lower than i should be on
i don't like that
knew it i knew i didn't
pretty much i should just be suspicious
of any uh
but oh wait no that means the toy ones
are whoa you [ __ ] again
you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
god damn you [ __ ]
all right hold the hold your likes and
subscribes hold them hold them hold the
likes and subscribes
hold them i i keep checking
the vent cams
and i don't see a bonnie he
does he he does go through the fence
correct
i'm not crazy about that
it's been a while
but i'm pretty sure he has to go through
the then right
and i look
and i see
and
he's not there you know i
think i'm crazy
i don't think i'm crazy
i don't think i'm crazy
it's all i have to say about that
oh it's so
calm that's nice
oh it's not gone anymore
all right
get ready gang
it's about to go down
oh you know what it is
it could be
that
they moved so quickly through the vent
and because my last thought was that
balloon boy was there
therefore
when i see it empty it's actually a sign
of danger that must be what it is
is that they're already through and
therefore i should be worried
so i should just listen for literally
any event
any vent noise
like that that's a venom noise that i
don't like it could be
bad stuff
that's bad ah see any vent noise anytime
i hear a ven while the camera's up
i have to be ready to put that down
and i think i heard of that noise again
i did no i didn't that was just lucky
at least we got the other characters
coming out faster
so i haven't heard any vents if you
don't hear event noise there is no
reason to put that mask down in my
honest opinion
i was wrong see i did that just in case
i was wrong
weird though okay i heard a lot of vent
noise
a lot of that
i almost feel like
bonnie's silent he's so sneaky oh god
oh
am i a dead man i thought i was a dead
man
i thought that was like completely
unforgiving
oh
vent sounds
are you gone
get a little uh hot in these rhinos
there you are
good thing they wait their turn i think
that might be
bonnie nah i thought
man i did you know night five is is
pretty dicey
like it's manageable it's manageable
it's definitely not the insanity
that i've experienced before
i gotta i gotta get out of the habit of
looking both ways
i just gotta go one way and remember
that's really the key oh my god nope i'm
not gonna break my
muscle memory just yet
knew it i knew it that damn
then sound
oh then sound and boom nope
maybe now
[Music]
okay
now i think i got a good handle on it
because you hear all of that clumping
clomping
slumping slumping
and that's just
it just means that you
i forgot that's what i did that oh
that's what i did i used the time that
the mask was on
to look over to the other side that's
what i did
that's why i did the compromise
yes it's technically faster if you only
have to go one direction but it's more
consistent
if you do
bull
and if you just assume that you're going
to
come on i saw you
what what is happening what
what's happening
i saw
toy
chica
i i did didn't you guys see toy chica
what happened
they are moving in and out like
crazy fast
hmm
okay i gotta get those likes and
subscribes ready boys
boys and girls
it's about to go down
it's about to go down
it's about to go down
oh that's a lot of clumping
get him ready
here he comes
any minute
oh no oh no oh no oh no
oh no guys oh no i'm alive
i'm alive i'm alive i can't believe it
i'm alive i'm alive
ah that's the problem
slam them slam them in
slam them in
god this it's fun right
ah there it is
there it is
of the good stuff the good stuff now the
question is
the question is
i know there's night six and then custom
night
i know there's night six
the question is should i keep going
right
like that's fun because but after that
it starts to get a bit more frustrating
right and then
i don't even want to talk about 20 mode
ever
just forget it
no maybe i don't know
but
this has been a revisit of this game if
you want to see me actually play it
there's the old playlist old videos over
there i think
i don't know what do you guys think
nah you know what
i want to give my full
i want to get my full understanding of
this game as far as like looking back on
it from where it came from and really
how it started to set the stage for
people to have a lot of things to chew
on in the universe i still love this
game i think five nights at freddy's 2
i don't know if it's my favorite but
it's it would be a it would be a close
race
for top i think it like is a special
place
in my heart because like it was just
really exciting to have something very
different and it's still scary it's
still intense and it still feels fun to
play it's very snappy and all that stuff
but also just like
i don't know it's really held up it is
really held up
i think it has held up pretty well
all right i'm gonna give it one attempt
all right just one if i can beat it in
one go we're all happy and we get to
like good stuff
good good stuff i'll give it one go i'll
give it one go
and if i don't beat it that's that
but
you guys got to remember
the trailer for in space with markiplier
is linked down in the description below
if you didn't know
the show's coming out in about three
weeks
very very soon you are going to be able
to see
in space with markiplier
on this channel for free and the trailer
if you haven't seen it is linked in the
description below so go check that out
and then come back or when i try this
once
go see it after that link in the
description okay let's give this a try
i mean now that i got the recipe down i
don't think that there's going to be too
much that could throw me off from this
because so long as i know exactly when
i can make these choices that's good
what on earth are you doing there didn't
you get the memo
just finish your shift is safer than
trying to leave in the middle of the
night
uh
we have one more event scheduled for
tomorrow a birthday you'll be on day
shifts wear your uniform
stay close to the animals
make sure they don't hurt anyone okay uh
for now just make it through the night
uh when the place eventually opens again
i'll probably take a nice shift myself
okay good night good luck
okay
so oh god trying to
multitask here
so
as you can tell someone happened to
something the bite 87 or the bite 80
whatever
occurred
it's happened it happened now was that
the bite of 87 it was it just happened
it's no good for anybody
but you know me i gotta get that bread
so nothing's gonna stop me from a
paycheck was that balloon boy
yeah it was
i was about to i don't think i made that
i made it
i made it that's a shock
i was about to drop it down
because i was like oh that sounds like
something
and yet it was
oh i oh i touched it i touched you saw
my mouse god it didn't go
i'm alive
i've ascended i've ascended past the
realm of reality speed is my demon
you can't touch my speed apparently
that must have been like by
by the a millisecond i got that in there
that would have been like
the closest one
oh that was not fast
ah still okay though shockingly hey
shut up
i know that's you balloon
oh
i forgot to flash the flashlight
that makes sense
that makes sense
well
i said i'd do one time
i'll do one more that was pitiful that
was pitiful i can do better than that
i can do better than that i can do
better but this is the last try if i
even if it's pathetic
we're going to end it there i'll give my
clothing closing thoughts i'll give my
clothing away
cloakbrand.com
i knew i got something you get that itch
that you're like i'm am i forgetting
something when you don't do one of the
things that you were prescribed to do
it sounds like there's an animatronic
looking at you when the cameras change
for some reason
i don't know why
see that's kind of why i want to not get
in the habit of putting the mask down
every time
is because it's much easier and
technically better
to not have to do it all the time
okay
there's a foxy
there he is
yeah i gotta remember to hit him before
i go in here and do an extended rewind
i know you're coming around the corner
here guys
i know you are
oh my god oh my god
wrong buttons bad buttons bad buttons
bad buttons bad
what come on
oh
god damn it
okay i'm expecting another one right at
raft for you yep
knew that
okay we're clear ah calm night calm
night guys
easy
oh
no
[Music]
oh my god i'm in the wrong spot
oh god come on let me
let me there we go
okay easy now that i got this rhythm i'm
good to go
easy peasy
so specifically i think the voice line
for balloon boy is high he says hi
and that's
nope nope nope
apparently not
that that high that was definitely
i'm getting behind on this
music box
i was just checking to see if balloon
boy was there
there's gonna be one right now nope
my instincts
oh my god
[ __ ]
ready golden freddy
oh come on
i hope he was gone
no he wasn't okay
god damn you balloon [ __ ]
balloon [ __ ]
you balloon [ __ ]
uh he just doesn't go away if you lift
up the mask afterwards he just doesn't
go away
well
hope that foxy doesn't come down
well there he is all right
that's all for today
that's all for today
i can beat it i've beat it before i have
all right fine i'll beat it again
all right i'm going again i'm going
again we're going again
we're going again
this will be
the one
if that balloon
[ __ ] decides to obey
if he can behave for one second
then i wouldn't have to worry so much
i feel like recruit neurons back to be
able to like get back in the mental
state of like okay what am i looking for
what am i bouncing on
what am i going for here what am i doing
come on
let me come on come on oh what there
why'd that take so long
probably had multiple moving at the same
time
i hear you
if you can see you can't see from
anywhere right i don't think so
balloon boy is still locked up
just being a little try hard at the
moment don't mind me
i'll have fun once i get to a
comfortable place where these guys
aren't breathing down my neck
i don't know why why do i check the
sides at all i have no idea well
actually no that's a good idea because i
i keep forgetting about the toy
animatronics
but they still are an issue
i just haven't seen him in a while and
that's that's my overconfidence you know
so i i know that i'm doing this like
routine habit
of checking both sides at the same time
for a reason i know i am
and it will become apparent when i do
not die
you know what me mean you know what me
mean
come on let me see let me see down that
hallway come on come on oh there we go
all right we got dangerous just
digestive oh i hear i heard that and
nope
that was one loading end and shoop i
knew it
the real trick is like if you hear two
in a row
something might be out there if you hear
three in a row something's definitely
out there
i'd rather be wrong sometimes
okay who is clambering
uh back around for another triumph
all right easy peasy
easy peasy the peas are ease
couldn't be easier but here come the toy
animatronics
so this is the interesting thing and
this is why
i'm checking these i hear that oh my god
what did i see down that hallway what
the hell was that what the hell did i
see did you guys see that
god damn it
oh
prick
getting caught in a bad point
oh
[Applause]
god damn it i don't think i made that
rick
frick
i see why it gets difficult i see why i
see why all right
right that's golden freddy i remember
him sitting in the thing maybe he was
just like so
barely there
that
i was just quick enough to get them gone
okay
all right
this is the one
this is the one
i got it
i get it i'm remembering
because the trick is like making sure
that this is almost always full so
knowing when you can if if i get down
here and i know nothing's in the vents
i don't have to spend that much time
going back and forth
and i can just that's this is this is
what's really going to save me time is
just being able to know that wasn't
right just go to one side that's it i
can't keep going back to the other side
over and over again
oops nope that's wrong
no god
all right
my muscle memory is needing a little bit
of recalibration at the moment but this
this is how we save time
i i i flubbed the timing i i forgot to
go left again
but that is much quicker it's much
quicker
but i just got to remember not to bring
the camera back up before i die
you know what i mean you know you know
what i mean you get what i'm saying
you get what i'm saying
but that is much quicker it's just like
my muscle memory is not used to that oh
no
not one of these
i got you i got you i got you there you
go
here you go
[Music]
there you go
you want cake
cake
get some cake or gob
[Music]
[Music]
oh
ah
oh
the lore
all right this is gonna be the one i got
this because i got the new
pattern that i should have been doing a
while ago
and i will get there
ah sorry couldn't save him couldn't save
him
nothing i could do
okay it's this
bring this down flash that one left okay
that's the pen
oh
i'm off
oh i almost did the thing
because i'm used to doing it on the left
side
i need to not do that
reverse it every time
this goes up
there we go and that's that
up put that down
there
press that go here that this is the
power
oh still hesitating
thank you thank goodness it doesn't uh
go uh go down before it's supposed to
you know what i mean
oh you know what it automatically allows
me to go up when i'm good
by default
i waited extra long that time just
because i didn't trust it
this is better this is better
i wonder if is this what i was doing for
20 minutes i
making it harder on myself if i was
yeah thankfully if you get it down in
time you literally can't put the the
helmet back up
too soon
like it just always does it
at the right time
i'm getting it
i'm getting it with good
time oh
come on
oh my god
i'm really loving it guys
okay back in
back up shockingly back up
shockingly back up
oh my god
i don't think
that anything can appear in the vents as
you're there you have to have like a
like a changing event of lifting the
camera
i think that's that's i think that's
right
like nothing can move unless you
change the scene
like when i if i'm waiting for say
one to go away
i think i could just
quickly flash the background and then go
to the computer if i needed to set it
without worrying about
something being a problem right
i think
oh
my god
i'm okay
i knew i heard that high and i was like
probably
doing extra long just in case
i'm gonna get caught oh i've been
flashing my flashlight way too much
incoming
okay real oh my god
oh i hear that
oh you gotta give me something man
you gotta give me something
keep working my way back up very slowly
okay it's five
that was definitely
i'm gonna run out of flashlight if i'm
not careful
i hear you
yeah the only big difference is balloon
boy
i think what happens is the reason he
says hi twice
i think anyway
is because
he
then this is just a guess
but i think what happens is he wants to
come out but he's stopped
before he's able to so he has to repeat
it again
that's what i think anyway i might be
wrong about that get those likes and
subzo slammin
hey i still got it a little bit i mean
that wasn't 20 20 mode but it was good
not very good
wow
[Music]
wow
wow
who is the ceo of fazbear entertainment
i don't even remember
well we did it guys we did it
together with the power of friendship
we did it
uh and i will not be doing
custom night i will not i will not be
doing it because
i'm okay and i feel confident in my
decisions
let's just try it
i'm just curious to see what it was like
but you better go in the link in the
description below and you better watch
the trailer to space
i watched it a hundred times and then
many of you watched me watch it a
hundred times a hundred times
so you better be ready oh god
hi
i'm just seeing i'm just seeing
cause i'm kind of curious
i don't know what do i do with golden
freddy i forget
oh i'm doing the wrong
loop
i need to check right left then left
right
oh hey buddy
oh this is where it gets in trouble
because they just keep coming so fast
that there's really nothing you can do
to get time to be able to wind up the
box i have time to wind up the box
i'm shocked
oh i i i thought about i meant to flash
before i put the thing up all right i'm
not going to make attempts at 20 20 mode
that is okay i'm gonna give my full
understanding this actually went longer
than i thought it would i did i thought
i was gonna do like an hour the last
time i did a revisited you know i just i
played for like two nights i actually
played through six nights um pretty much
beating the game
uh
except for the 20 mode but i could
totally see with like my muscle memory
and getting back into it i think i could
do
uh 20 mode with a lot of attempts but i
just don't have the time to and i've i i
don't want to do it again you know so
the game really holds up it's really
nice i'm very happy with it you know it
it it turned out
to be an experience where i actually
enjoyed myself i beat it all in one
sitting you know back in the old days of
doing like
15 minute let's plays here and there and
now you know like doing the whole game
in one it's it's really cool to see i i
had a great time with this thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
for being here with me if this was
nostalgic for you thanks for being here
with me
and uh i know i've been harping on it
all video and i'm
not sorry in the least about that
because the show's gonna be great and i
know you're gonna love it i really do
know you're gonna love it i'm super
proud of this it's the best thing that
i've ever made i'm not saying it's the
best thing ever made it's the best thing
i've ever made and i'm just like
incredibly proud of it and for it to
come out on my 10-year anniversary of
posting videos on april 4th um is just
really really special to me like it's
incredibly special so check out the
trailer link is in the description below
please check it out i will know if you
didn't and i will come to your house and
i will beat you up
that's
a lie i won't do that but i might
i might appear under your bed in the
middle of the night just like uh five
nights at freddy's 4 that might happen
because i know i can see on my phone the
analytics of you if you don't click that
link in the description i will know
i will know and i will find you i will
punish you
but check it out
trailer's great cut it myself sound
editing was great effects are great the
whole team's great show's gonna be great
thank you and uh i'll probably the next
revisit i'll do will be five nights at
freddy's three which will be very
interesting because that's probably my
least favorite but i wonder if it will
still be my least favorite after all
this time
thank you
let me know what you thought down in the
comments if you're watching this in the
future and
as always i will see you
in the next video
bye bye
bye guys goodbye
bye